es momento de hablar de economía quien
france24 y por ello recibo con mucho
gusto a daniela blandón daniela nuestra
especialista económica ya el nuevo
presidente en bolivia como recibe
revisarse el país en términos económicos
daniel allan muy buenas noches pues el
economista luis arce es muy conocido por
haber sido el cerebro del auge económico
ocurrido en casi 13 años de gobierno de
evo morales en casi todo este tiempo
luís arce fue ministro de economía y en
este lapso tuvo que ver por ejemplo con
la nacionalización del sector de
hidrocarburos ahora como presidente
promete volver a la industrialización
para sustituir importaciones y
renegociar la deuda externa también
promocionar una empresa nacional de
fármacos con base en medicina
tradicional ahora vamos a ver cómo
recibe la economía alan pues antes de la
pandemia bolivia era uno de los países
que más crecía en la región sin embargo
en 2019 avanzó apenas un 22 por ciento
esa fue su cifra más baja desde que
morales asumió el poder ya como efecto
del cobi 19 la caída acumulada en el
segundo trimestre de s
fue del 11 1 % si hablamos de desempleo
cárcel se enfrentará a una tasa del 11
8% en este momento mientras que en
pobreza la cifra más reciente que es con
corte a 2019 habla de un 37,2 por ciento
de la población es decir adam a más de 4
millones de personas hoy a pesar de el
coronavirus china continúa su senda de
crecimiento económico bueno por lo menos
así lo dicen las cifras desde beijing
que hacen suponer que el país asiático
será uno de los muy pocos que podrá
darse el lujo de crecer este año según
las proyecciones de los organismos
multilaterales en el tercer trimestre el
pib de china aumenta un 4.9 por ciento
interanual quiere decir que es frente al
mismo período del año pasado y en el
acumulado del año ya va creciendo 0 7%
en este gráfico se ve la tendencia a
alan el país vino de un avance del 3,2
por ciento en el segundo trimestre todo
esto después de que el primer trimestre
el pib chino se contraerá por primera
vez desde 1976 en un 6,8 por ciento
y vamos a brasil 10 que suspendió
temporalmente los aranceles a la
importación de algunos productos bueno
desde que empezó en la pandemia los
precios de productos como la soja y el
maíz han subido vertiginosamente al
punto que contribuyeron a que la
inflación se disparara 1 064 en
septiembre por eso se van a impulsar las
importaciones vía eliminación de
aranceles que hoy son del 8% con
excepción de los países de mercosur en
el caso de la soja esta medida va hasta
el 15 de enero próximo y para el maíz se
extiende hasta el 31 de marzo en
septiembre ya se había tomado una medida
similar con el arroz después de que
alcanzará precios récord está uno de los
beneficiados con esta medida muy
seguramente será eeuu con el que justo
hoy el gobierno de jair bolsonaro firmó
una serie de acuerdos de inversión con
esta noticia muy interesante daniela y
es que américa latina volvió a la
actividad milenaria del trueque como un
efecto de la pandemia sí señor
recordemos primero que el trueque
consiste básicamente en cambiar un bien
por otro yo le doy a usted algo que a mí
me
se le sirve y usted me da algo que usted
a usted le sirve y eso principal
característica es que no hay
intermediación de dinero en medio de la
crisis generada por la pandemia países
como méxico colombia argentina y ahora
cuba desempolvaron esa forma primitiva
de comercio para superar las clases de
alimentos se han creado en este país
grupos a través de la red de telegrama
allí se intercambia ropa y juguetes por
alimentos y medicinas la crisis
económica en la isla no da tregua no
solamente hay demoras en las
importaciones sino también problemas de
abastecimiento interno y es por eso que
no es raro ver largas filas en
supermercados para comprar artículos
básicos por eso cada vez son más quienes
subasta en sus pertenencias por redes
sociales o las cambian por otras mejores
buenos con los indicadores económicos
del día bueno estoy desde cero con
pérdidas en medio del escepticismo
porque aprueben un nuevo plan de
estímulos fiscales antes de las
elecciones en europa con excepciones de
españa' también hubo cierres negativos
el mercado está muy pendiente hablan de
las negociaciones del éxito que
iniciaron
y nuevamente y en américa latina'
resultados mixtos en argentina hubo un
nuevo récord del precio del dólar
paralelo que obligó al gobierno a tomar
medias la cifra el día el 46% que
cayeron en el primer semestre las
concesiones de visados o permisos de
residencia de inmigrantes en los países
de la ocde o el club de países ricos
pues la ocde dice que estos trabajadores
son los que se han llevado la peor parte
de la pandemia
muchas gracias daniela por tu reporte y
ustedes por su compañía siga con más en
francés 24
[Música]